spicy clam a noodle soup followed by
sweet Moorish banana and coconut
fritters for dessert first up my dessert
banana fritters take you bananas and to
get them really nice and soft just rough
banana sip together flour and baking
powder sugar into the flour then add
coconut for texture and a pinch of salt
sounds strange in the dessert but it
works brilliantly especially where the
fritters makes the batter nice and crisp
start crush and use the back of the fork
and just push it against the side of the
bowl and then once you mix that through
gonna make that mix now slightly
fragrant with some lime zest now the
line just really elevates the sort of
richness and the denseness of the banana
cover with cling film so doesn't get a
skin on top
sit that in the fridge for 15 minutes as
the banana fritter mixture rests and
getting on with my broth for the noodle
and clam soup
fish stock is the base bring that up to
the boil now to take that broth to
another level in with chopped shallots
fresh ginger and a whole chili seeds and
all I actually quite like it spicy I
just chopped once they into the broth
bring up to the ball and let it simmer
Gallagher
it's sort of almost like a softer
version of ginger slightly milder you
can use gallon ghoul face but I prefer
the fresh stuff the stems for coriander
will finish it off with e heads and
that's what endeared me to the Southeast
Asian style of cooking across my travels
there was there's no waste in lime
leaves for me one of my favorites
incredibly pungent strong full of flavor
very acidic but gives a really nice
aroma to the broth just tear them in now
the lemongrass so the secret here that's
for all the flavors right at the very
end so you take the back of the knife
and you just bash it's all that flavor
is gonna run out in seconds that's the
base of the broth down there the longer
you leave it the more intense it gets
whilst the prof infuses the soak your
rice noodles in boiling water for 10
minutes just enough time to fry your
fritters the batter now is ready use a
metal spoon to drop the batter to the
bottom of the pan
I mean they hit that oil they puff up
that's why it's important to put your
spoon into the oil so the mixture runs
off and Crais is lovely little fritter
then you gently fry get a slotted spoon
and ice it carefully
turn them over smell of that lime is
extraordinary fry for 2 to 3 minutes as
they start floating they signifies the
fact that they're cooked off with a gas
and just drained are those beauties
lovely sprinkling when they're hot with
sugar actually sticks them they're done
ready to go the last job before serving
the clams never be scared of cooking
shellfish the most important rule is if
they are slightly opened a millimeter
discard it make sure mussels plans are
always tight cook the clams for just 3
to 5 minutes or until they're all open
bring that up to the boil and this is
where we finish the broth touch of fish
sauce a little sprinkle of sugar drain
your noodles into the bowl adhi texture
some delicious bean sprouts get your
lime fresh squeezed lime juice in
beautiful
literally as a stock comes up to the
boil if the clams open automatically so
they're cooked beautifully
the flavor from inside the clam has
enhanced the broth smell is incredible
the clams cooked finished with fresh
coriander and serve they have a perfect
lunch a delicious spicy clamp noodle
with an amazing banana fritter my spicy
clam noodle soup and banana and coconut
fritters made in minutes and proof
you only need to travel as far as your
kitchen to get the taste of Southeast
Asia
they efficient over the soul get your
salt and just start back in the radicals
just touch them for a springy firm
texture